here we are at the NBA all-star tech
conference i'm joined by scott static
and paul jacobs chairman of qualcomm as
well as co-owner of the Sacramento Kings
Paul you're obviously here for a big
all-star weekend but today specifically
you're talking about wearables why do
you like them so much well it's the next
big thing we talked about smartphones
being a billion unit market well
wearables are going to be a partner to
your smartphone and therefore it's going
to be a big big market for us to sell
into but also it's going to do things
for people's item you're going to give
people information about their health
and what they're doing and this whole
notion that the phone is going to be at
the center of a universe of sensors and
things in the environment around us
maybe even inside our bodies and it's
going to change the way that we we're
healthy and our doctors take care of us
and all sorts of things were you
surprised last week with Under Armour's
big announcement really going big in
this text space with my fitness pal I
love that idea I think it's a great
brand for for these kinds of things and
these technologies are going to get
built into our clothes and all the
things that we have around us I mean so
we're talking about we wear watches we
talk about glasses you know headphones
things like that that now start think
about shirts and shorts and shoes and
all those kinds of things they'll all be
instrumented to and aren't under
armour's a great brand how do you want
your team twos well obviously you know
you want to get a lot of telemetry off
the players you want to know how the
players doing I think it'll be
interesting actually to see which guys
when they're standing at the free-throw
line with all those fans cheering and
screaming when the game's on the line I
bet you the fans would be really
interested to know what their heart
rates are doing and stuff like that well
i mean the NFL is putting them in
shoulder pads are the players they're
tracking and we're going to see it that
wearable tech you think about that
analytics people think points and
rebounds and assists now we're talking
about health analytics exam Mark Cuban
wants his players respiration rates he
wants their sweat how much sweat is
being produced know when to substitute
they'll measure in an optimal situation
like practice when the guy get says he's
tired and then if you can mimic those
metrics during a game it's time to get
them out exactly it's going to become
part of the game it's gonna be part of
the game Emirates it's definitely there
in sports and then we're going to just
see it in in everyday life and when
we're all wearing these things now to do
very simple things like try
our steps but now the newer ones are
having you know heart rate monitors in
them and eventually we're going to see
all sorts of other kinds of monitoring
going on in these things let's not kid
ourselves if LeBron where's beats by dre
the kids want beats by dre and it's
LeBron Randy so if LeBron where's this
and says this is what I use to optimize
my game obviously the retailer's go
there as well yeah no I think it's true
what have you learned created done at
Qualcomm that you've now brought over to
the team well some of the stuff that
we're already doing is we're doing
beacons so when you walk into the arena
your phone will light up say welcome to
the arena when you leave it says hey
here's how the traffic patterns are when
you're in the game and you want to go to
I don't get something to eat it says
okay here's where the lines are shorter
or longer so that stuff's already
happening the beacon technology but
we're building a new arena in sacramento
right now and that thing is going to
have the best wireless connectivity of
any arena and why is that because we
want to give people in the arena
different camera angles that they can
get to we may even want to do this
augmented or virtual reality where
you're like explode like you're sitting
unfortunately due to ticket prices when
we see these extraordinary arenas built
sort of a sad outcome corporations buy
up the box seats and true fans dads and
their sons aren't there anymore because
they just can't afford it well I think
we're going to have great product for
for all ranges of fans and one of the
reasons and we know this one of the
reasons why that team is in Sacramento
it's not just because we wrote a check
to buy the team it's because the fans
were incredibly passionate there and the
NBA wanted those fans to be there we
want those fans to be I mean you guys
are going to accept Bitcoin yeah we do
that already why why do you like Bitcoin
so much it doesn't seem to be working a
lot of other places no it's just a cool
thing you know you you want to be ahead
on technology and of course with
technology sometimes they take bets on
things maybe it does pan out maybe it
doesn't pan out but it's good to be at
the leading edge just keep challenging
yourself anyone actually paying a
Bitcoin oh I'm sure that we have things
that are paid with Bitcoin but you know
what happens with Bitcoin you get the
Bitcoin and you translate it into
dollars pretty quickly so what's scaring
some owners now those fans are opting to
stay at home if I can have an experience
at home that is equal to or better
the internet experience that's a problem
for a lot of teams especially in
football fans are staying away is it
make the game make the experience so
compelling that people will be fighting
to get in the door how do you do that
the technology allow you to do that I
think so i think you know giving people
the access to the kinds of things they
have at home so you can get the
different camera angles and things like
that while you're in the seats I think
that's great but this virtual reality
stuff what remains to be proven is what
sort of bandwidth do we need to give
people in order to have a really
immersive experience so you really feel
like you're sitting courtside that may
for a little while at least only be
possible in the arena do you want to see
basketball players wear GoPros oh I
think having people wear cameras and it
so you know if I'm a if I'm sitting at
home or I'm sitting in the arena or the
stadium and I can feel like I'm the one
that's running through the crowd I'm the
one that's going to dump me ray was so
ahead of its time to remember years ago
the NBA tried to put cameras in the
locker room at halftime just to take the
fan closer and I got some pushback after
Melissa like you I can pass but there
was pushback from the players back down
talking about privacy yeah now it seemed
but now it seems they're all they all
want their they're all instagramming
they're all on snapchat during halftime
it's like they want to bring their
personal fans closer to the game so it
seems like a better partnership exists
today between player and owner and the
chance to do these things yeah I think
everybody wants to build that kind of
direct relationship with their fans they
feel good about it the fans feel good
about them they know sort of a lot more
about their personal life and let's face
it i mean one of the things i love about
being an owner is getting to see the
inside scoop of what's going on it's
very fun and that experience should be
available to other people too did you
consider buying the Clippers no why oh I
was involved with the Kings we were
we're really happy to be involved with
the kings and I actually knew Steve was
was kind of interested and he's got a
little bit more money than me so how
much you think then nets are gonna go
for oh I don't know you know it's hard
hard to say but it should be I think the
valuations of all the teams are going up
obviously we got a great new TV deal the
thing that I love about the NBA also
though is that we have this huge
international fan base that were only
starting the tap now and I think that's
a huge opportunity for us as well so
valuation of the teams are going to be
great is your new coach a huge
opportunity for you I'm really that army
I'm really smart it's better be hit
DeMarcus Cousins better be happy with
them yeah but now true or false I've
heard this is true tell me true or false
vivec has gone into the coach's office
in the past and said I utilized this
defense with my daughter's team we
should try it here I don't think so no I
don't know you know the vector he's
beautifully why shouldn't it and involve
know he is definitely passionate and
that's a good thing you want to have a
passionate owner but I think it will be
interesting to see the personalities
between Vivek and George Karl and I
think we know which one though George
Karl is the six Williams coach in NBA
history I think we're gonna be listening
to him now what's you're truly
passionate job is it Qualcomm or is it
the team oh no I'm the most i still love
technology I'm that's what I'm all about
and the reason why I went to be
executive chairman is because then i get
to focus in on new technologies and i
don't have to do some of the other stuff
that comes along with the CEO job that's
not quite as fun so I that's my thing I
love technology